Emilee I am breaking up with you
when
Like right now
this is it, you are middle of love it
Mom
You Poor Sam
Look how firm you are
we're going to South America where the
hell are we
we're in the middle of the Amazon let's
not play the blame game
no one knows really good to blame is a
more your fault or my fault
I can't fight with you right now I'm
starving oh my god Oh phone turkey legs
I am gonna focus on you and me on the beach a with
me I can't go to South America
what are you telling now, I can't go to
Ecuador you know it's a non-refundable
trip right I mean I don't want to make
it about money because the money comes
and goes but I don't have anymore right
coming right now so it's breaking up
with you when like right now this is it
you're in the middle of it you don't
want all of us you don't want to lose
that I didn't know just know all right
this is the thing you don't have any
direction in life what does that mean it
means you're not going anywhere you're
not doing it okay you know what I am so
sorry honestly but I'm sorry but I want
to see other people
excuse me yeah you're great but I was a
lot going on right now
yeah I'm heartbroken
I actually kind of caught a PC you mom
could you lean out a little bit
here but what is it what that is a rape
rape which that's a racist what this is
a dog whistle mom are you all afraid
these dogs are gonna rape me because
that's just going to do that well these
dog is a dog did they look like rapist
to you whatever
why don't you just say thank you mom
thank you
I've hiked on mountains in Iran I run
with Bulls in spain ain't no gettin poison
Blowfish in Japan to me though is my
moment
to make life worth living I love
everything you're saying okay I'm for
your endless I think you and I thought
the fool remembers never have more
drinks than you have tip to tip to
breathe I know how many times I have did
you just give me bangs your eyes I don't
even know what danger aren't things like
this that's kind of a they make that
thing I thank you things are on go go he
rotted out
barb your while it out right now Thank
You barb okay
can I help you ma'am
oh my god our vacuum hi I'm Linda
Kalitta hi look you don't even
understand that the ordeal that we've
just been through we really need to get
the US consulate in Bogota as soon as
possible kind of how would you know the
easiest way the easy way let's get
something else
oh you've got not raised to the north
junks east and west
well the mighty one rivers she's to the
south there is no easy trick there's a
reason they call Colombia the sack of
the Jaguar tell you what I've got a slow
boat headed down a river I can take each
along the Amazon and stretch it up north
names Roger Simmons both stocks just out
back crews getting to see where the
answer speaks and I'll take him with
them and come back for you yeah chicken
wings whoo ladies
yeah polite murder not oh honey if you
look awful thank you I would like to eat
right here with you my mom gave her mom
I'm not you from us mama my mom thank
you mama
pack your bag we're going to South
America what is this a rapist this is a
dog whistle
we need an amazing adventure
I'm starving my body eating it felt like
God we had sandwiches on the truck okay
those are like all bread
I'm serious almond Armando my child it's
Mother's Day we need an adventure Lambie
ultimate getaway with mom
I chose you got to wear your best well
it wasn't related mother
and we I can't go to South America wait
that's all so I'm breaking up with you
when like right now this is it you're in
the middle of it you look oh thank you
pack your bag we're going to South
America absolutely not my trip is
non-refundable
oh my god the system's a rapist is the
dog with are you afraid I'm gonna get
raped by dog tom is very dangerous it
feels like you're putting rolling I'm
just here when you need it here
we need an amazing adventure this is a
real phobia by being locked in the trunk
I think everybody's got that one we're
in the middle of the Amazon I chose you
not to wear your flip-flops
it wasn't puzzle related mother snatched
wrist film is not yet rated
Emily and breaking up with you when like
right now I don't want to lose that
if you poor thing you guys shot through
the heart that's what he was the best
you'll ever do mom we're going to South
America
mom you put fondle my child
I need your help mom and I got kicked
out hey department do you have a
commando squad for criminal drive for a
crime they didn't commit
so like dat da team is do you have an
eight team snatched
here's to nothing getting in the way of
our adventure Emily I can't go to South
America with my band is really blowing
up right now and where I'm going
there's going to be like a ton of
inspiration inspiration I keep talking
over you but it's counting like you're
singing pussy it
I heard that too poor thing you look
awful thank you I'll just you this this
is a long hug all right okay mom look
how fun you were hacked your back we're
going to South America
absolutely not everybody knows you need
two years to plan a vacation you don't
do anything fun anymore
that's not true I'll be taking sculpting
lessons at the Y Dada
I told you I would not acknowledge that
as frightening and you made that okay
hola I came from Middleton what's going
on oh well would welcome Oh welcome
they're not serving on the way already
but I've got it why are you dressed like
a beekeeper who is Damon you were to get
so much on you put on too much I'm we're
going out things I'm definitely not
you're going to miss this whole trip
everything shouldn't be so scary hi I'm
Jamie
that was not what it looks like it
looked like you were washing it with
your honor the thing I need is an
amazing adventure where the hell are we
the scenic route we did you come to
South America I never wanted to cover
the cultural experience I don't speak
any Spanish I know what they called me
at the restaurant
buthow which making princess prettier no
it means whore check that I'm going to
get it out of that
don't man you can take added you that's
a sexy story okay those people want
young beautiful females do you are both
safe it would be so lucky to fuck us
kids oh no I will be very unlucky you're
like melted candles